الغطس البارد او حمام الماء المثلج انتشر
مؤخرا كتحد على التيك توك وشارك فيه من
المشاهير لها عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وهو نظام تدريبي اصبح شائعا ضمن العنايه
البدنيه خاصه بعد ترويج العديد من
الرياضيين له كوسيله تسرع تعافي العضلات
بعد التدريبات الشاقه ليس فقط الرياضيين
من ينصحون بحمام الماء للمثلج لكن يشير
باحثون من جامعه بورناموس الى ان السباحه
في الماء البارد مفيده لصحه الدماغ
ولتقليل التوتر هاي بتلزم لنا رغم كل
هذا والتي تقوم كثير من الشعوب بالقيام
بها سواء في دول اسيويه كاليابان وكثير من
الدول الاوروبيه الى انها تظل مثيره للجدل
مع تحذيرات من خطر على مرضى القلب بعيدا
عن هذا الجدل سنذهب الى روسيا مع مراسلنا
عبد الجواد الرش الذي سيقوم بهذه التجربه
مباشره عبد الجواد يعني ما شاء الله عليك
هل هناك يعني
طقوس لهذه نروح على عبد الجواد اول نروح
على عبد الجواد
[موسيقى]
عبد الجواد هل هناك طقوس تقوم بها قبل
القفز البارده او المتجمده في طقوس معينه
عبد الجواد بدك تبردنا معك اليوم
تيشرت طالع
صباح الخير ليس كشفت كل الاسرار حول
يعني عندما تسمع باسم روسيا اول ما يخطر
في بال المراه هو الثلج والشقيع والبرد
ليس في العالم العربي ياتي الشتاء دون
استئذان ياتي محملا بالامطار والبرد ورهبه
الزكام والوضع يختلف من بلد عربي لاخر لكن
الوضع في روسيا كما تشاهد ياتي الشتاء في
موعده عندما لا يتواجد هذا الثلج وهذا
السقيع في الاراضي الروسيه يتململ الشعب
الروسي لذلك طبعا الروس تاقلموا بشكل كبير
مع الثلج دخل في حضارتهم وثقافتهم قد
يتساءل البعض ما الذي اتى بشعوب هذه
المنطقه التي لا تزيل يعني حلتها البيضاء
الا بضعه اشهر في السنه
الطباع للشعب الروسي يعني ومعرفه الثلج
الرابط فيها طيب
ما هي الفوائد وهل هناك
يعني السمر يقسم الكثير من من يمارس هذه
السباحه في المياه المتجمده على فوائد هذه
الرياضه الصحيه كثير منهم يعتبرونها رياضه
لكن عامه الناس يرون فيها احد انواع فنون
الجنون يعني لنشاهد هذا المشهد هذه هي
مجموعه من سباحي المياه المتجمده في موسكو
يعني هي مؤسسه رسميه مسجله لدى الاتحاد او
اللجنه الاولمبيه الروسيه كما نشاهد يعني
درجه حراره المياه هي الان تقترب من الصفر
والاحساس العام بالجو يقترب من ناقص 10
درجات درجه حراره المياه هي صفر والاحساس
العام بالجو هو ناقص عشر درجات ثمر
رح يخطف هلا عند الجواد ولا لا
غيرت رايك بس دير بالك على المايك يا عبد
الجواد
مصر يعني يا ليث ما هيك لا لسه يلا يلا
على المايك ما هيك خايف على المايك طبعا
لابد يعني من تجربه هذا الشيء يعني طيب
يلا انا معكم ليش تسمعني لاني راح اشيل
السماعه لذلك بدي منك بدي منك يا ليث ويا
سمر تعدوا على التنازلي من الخمسه عشره
تسعه ثمانيه سبعه سته خمسه اربعه ثلاثه
اثنين واحد تفضل
مباشره في صباح العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
يقفز في مياه بارده اتصل
معاه بس شوفوا كيف حركه الجسد مهمه راسا
اول ما نط بدو يلعبوا يتناولوا الطابه
الكره
شكلها راح يطلع ولا ما راح يطلع ما بعرف
راح يطلع ان شاء الله يطلع خليل عبد
الجواد
طلع يلا وين
كيف حلو الموضوع انه شوفوا اللي بيلعبوا
حواليه صاحيين مبكر الساعه بتوقع تسعه
صباحا او 8:00 صباحا في موسكو ولكن يعني
الكل هون رجع عنا
اني اريد اسويها ليث هذا ان شاء الله
ناويه عليها يا رب
على كل حال شكرا عبد الجواب عبد الجواد
كانت مغامره يعني فريده مباشره على صباح
العربيه هلا انا اعود الى راويه
مستحيل اعملها انا ميت البحر بدبي بكون
بردانه وما بنزل اعوذ فاذا اعطيتك 100 الف
دولار
انت الواحد هيك دايما بخاف من الهيك
مفاجات وهيك مغامرات بس لما يعملها
بلاقيها سهله هي مش المشكله لما يعملها
المشكله قبل ما يعملها عشان يخلي حاله
يعملها
مباشره على الهواء